يجب الا نستخف بروسيا فهي تتحضر
للاسوأ. هكذا قالها الناتو
وبوتين يقود الحرب من ارض
المعركة والجيش الاوكراني يعلن
حالة التأهب القصوى واوروبا.
امريكا لم تنفع نفسها كي تنفعنا.
وتسريب خطير يفضح واشنطن والفيفا
يرفض طلب زينيسكي وعرض مغر من
الرئيس الروسي لدول عربية.
اليابان باجراء عسكري خطير
وواشنطن ترحب وبكين ترد بقوة
وكيم جونغ يشرف على تجربة جديدة
وفريدة من نوعها وجيرانه
يستنجدون بالامن الدولي بينما
تركيا تعلن عن سلاح جديد ومرعب
وفرنسا تتملق للجزائر. بوتين
يدير دفة الحرب. الحرب لا تمضي
بعشوائية للروس. ووسط تقدم
القوات الروسية في مقاطعة
دونيتسك وبشكل مفاجئ وغير معلن.
بوتن يزور مطبخ القيادة الخاصة
للعملية العسكرية في اوكرانيا
وقد امضى بوتين يوما كاملا في
مقر القيادة بحسب وكالة نوفوستي.
وخلال ذلك درس رئيس الدولة عمل
هذه القيادة واستمع الى تقرير عن
سير العملية الخاصة كما عقد
اجتماعات منفصلة مع القادة.
واعرب عن استعداده لسماع كل
المقترحات والاجراءات للعملية
العسكرية. وكأن بوتين يقول لن
نترك اي شيء للصدفة. لتتعرض كييف
بعدها لاحدى اوسع الهجمات
الروسية منذ بدء الحرب. وتؤكد
السلطات هناك ان دفاعاتها الجوية
اسقطت سبعة وثلاثين صاروخا روسيا
من اصل اربعين استهدفة وبسبب
موجة القصف الاعنف منذ عشرة اشهر
انقطع التيار الكهربائي في جميع
انحاء البلاد. والسكان يهرعون
لمترو انفاق للهروب من صواريخ
الموت. هناك اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني حالة التأهب الجوي في
عموم البلاد. محذرا من موجة
هجمات روسية جديدة. بينما قالت
السلطات الموالية لروسيا انها
بدأت بانشاء فوق مرفق تخزين
النفايات النووية المستنفدة في
محطة النووية بهدف حمايتها من
المسيرات الاوكرانية على حد
قولها. عندها خرجت واشنطن واعلنت
عن مساعدات لاوكرانيا تضمنت
معدات وانظمة لمواجهة المسيرات
الروسية بحسب الخارجية
الامريكية. لترد وزارة الدفاع
الروسية معلنة دخول الفوج الثاني
من صور الخدمة القتالية في فرقة
وتشير الى انها ستعزز بشكل فعال
قوات الصواريخ الاستراتيجية
الروسية. وليس ببعيد عن ارض
المعركة. وتزامنا مع التصعيد
الميداني في اكثر من جبهة في
اوكرانيا اجرت القوات الروسية
والبلاروسية تدريبات مشتركة في
اراضي بلاروسيا. موسكو تستعد على
جميع المستويات يا سادة. فما هو
التالي ليعلنها الامين العام
لحلف الناتو ينس تلتومبيرج قائلا
يجب الا نستخف بروسيا فهي تستعد
لحرب طويلة. وتحشد مزيدا من
القوات ومستعدة لتكبد خسائر
كبيرة لاجل ذلك. فعلى الحلفاء
مواصلة دعم اوكرانيا بالسلاح.
ومن اصوات المدافع والاشتباكات
الى حرب التسريبات. بيانات مهمة
جدا تابعة للبنتاجون تم تسريبها
على الانترنت. تتعلق ببرامج
واشنطن البيولوجية العسكرية في
اوكرانيا حاول الامريكيون ابقاء
هذه المعلومات طي الكتمان. لكن
التسريب كشف اسماء المؤسسات
ومعاهد الدراسات والبحوث وكذلك
المقاولين ومنفذي المشاريع بحسب
موقع بارودي روما لتتأكد بدل
الاتهامات الروسية. اذا فكيف
سيرد مجلس الامن على ذلك؟ بينما
توجه موسكو عدستها نحو الدول
العربية بعرض روسي. وذلك
بانشاءها نظام بدون تأشيرة مع
دول الخليج العربية والدول
الحليفة وفقا لوكالة نافوستي اما
في القارة الاوروبية فقد حذرت
وكالة الدفاع الاوروبية من ان
الولايات المتحدة ربما لا تتمكن
من حماية اوروبا. وينبغي على
اوروبا شراء الاسلحة بشكل مشترك
وبمواصفات موحدة. ليظهر هنا
الرئيس الاوكراني محاولا استغلال
جماهيرية كأس العالم ليعرض ظهوره
في مقطع فيديو موجه للجماهير في
استاد قطر. لكنه تفاجأ برد فعل
سلبي من الفيفا بحسب شبكة سي ان
ان. عن روح الناس هربت من
السياسة للكورة. وانت وراهم
الصين واليابان صراع يقترب. في
بكين لكل فعل ردة فعل فلا توقف
ولا تراخي خصوصا امام الجيران.
التوتر يتصاعد بين الصين
واليابان على خلفية تعديل
الحكومة اليابانية لسياساتها
الدفاعية بمراجعة جذرية واعتبار
الصين اكبر تحد استراتيجي على
الاطلاق لامنها لتعلن اليابان
هذا الاعلان التاريخي بشأن خطتها
الدفاعية والذي لم تتخذه حتى في
الحرب العالمية الثانية. وهو
مضاعفة ميزانية الدفاع لاكثر من
ثمانين مليار دولار. يا لهذه
الارقام الفلكية لترد الصين
بارسال سرب من سفنها البحرية الى
القرب من اليابان. والدفاعات
اليابانية قالت ان سفنها
وطائراتها تراقب الوضع عن كثب.
فما الذي ينوي اصحاب العيون
الضيقة ان يفعلوه لتأتي الاهازيج
والزغاريد من الولايات المتحدة
مهنئة بالخطة الجديدة التي
اقرتها طوكيو. نعم. فلتفرحوا يا
هؤلاء. الدليفير الامريكي مستعد
لتلبية الطلبية اليابانية من
السلاح. ليصرح البيت الابيض ان
الخطة الدفاعية الجديدة لليابان
تهدف لتعزيز التحالف العسكري مع
الولايات بينما اعلن الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وقوفهم بجانب
اليابان في هذه اللحظة الحرجة
وان تحالفهم اساسي في منطقة
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ. نعم
فثمانون مليار دولار ليست قليلة.
تركيا تفاجئ المجتمع الدولي.
ليست كل الحروب تكسب في المعارك
وان تكسب تركيا حربها على
الطاولة افضل واسلم. هكذا يقولها
فبعد قصف مكثف بالمدفعية وغارات
لا تتوقف من الجانب التركي تدخل
الروس للوساطة بين انقرة ودمشق.
تركيا تنظر بايجابية للمقترح
الروسي. واردوغان بانتظار ان
يجلس على طاولة واحدة مع الاسد.
فالرئيس التركي مشغول باكبر خزان
للغاز في اوروبا الذي تصل سعته
التخزينية لاربعة مليارات
وستمائة مليون متر مكعب من الغاز
لجعل بلاده اكبر مركز لتوزيع
الغاز الى اوروبا. ليس ذلك فقط
بل ان هذا العثماني يتجه الان
للصناعة العسكرية. وفي اخر
اصداراته مقاتلة تركية بدون طيار
من انتاج شركة بايكر ماكينة
قادرة على الاقلاع بحمولة طن
ونصف من الذخيرة تستطيع التحليق
بسرعة تصل لتسعمائة كيلومتر في
الساعة لمدة خمس ساعات. اذا
الغاز سلاح قوي. والمسيرات سلاح
اخر ينضم للعتاد العثماني. وماذا
بعد يا اردوغان? انها تخبرني انك
ستسحب سفيرك من اسرائيل بعد ان
تم الكشف عن اكبر خلية تجسس
اسرائيلية باسطنبول تتكون من
اربعة واربعين شخصا وذلك حسب ما
نشرته البي بي سي البريطانية.
الاحداث كوريا الشمالية تعلن
اختبار محرك لتطوير سلاح
استراتيجي جديد بتوجيه واشراف من
الزعيم كيم جونغ اون لتتزامن
التجربة مع زيارة رئيس الوكالة
الدولية للطاقة الذرية لكوريا
الجنوبية الذي تعهد ببذل جهود
شاملة لوقف برنامج كوريا
الشمالية النووي. قالت وسائل
اعلام غربية ان وزير الداخلية
الفرنسي سافر الى برفقة زوجته.
واشارت الى ان هدف الزيارة هو
بحث مواضيع التعاون في الشؤون
الامنية ومكافحة الارهاب وفي
مجال الهجرة. لكن برأيكم ما هو
الهدف من هذه الزيارة بعد سقوط
ضابط في اعمال شغب ملك الاردن
يتوعد بتعامل حازم مع من يرفع
السلاح في وجه الدولة. وفي
بريطانيا سلسلة من الاضرابات
التاريخية تعم البلاد بعد ارتفاع
الاسعار الموظفين بزيادة الاجور.
بوتين يدير الحرب من غرفة
القيادة لتكثف موسكو هجماتها
الجوية والصاروخية وكييف تعاني
وتطلب النجدة. فهل سيلبي الغربي